[Music]
Paris Jackson poses for her first
photoshoot with boyfriend Michael snotty
and it is steamy
et has the exclusive pics check out
Michael Jackson's 18 year old daughter
in her musician boyfriend
the couple was all over each other
during the shoot making out and lounging
in a tub
here's Paris looking super glam and a
long red dress in black lipstick her
beau opted for a more revealing look
yeah he's naked except for some combat
boots Paris also paid tribute to her
late father in miss Shaw rocking a
vintage Michael Jackson tour t-shirt
paired with his signature fedora and
gloves it was her idea to wear it et
spoke with the photographer behind the
racy pics Troy Jensen who dished on the
couple's sexy shoot I set them in the
shot and she's wearing this red dress
this long dress with this leather jacket
she had his black lips and they would
just start making a like crazy so like
after like five or six shots he would
have black lips all over his face all
over his ears you know they were kissing
biting pulling hugging like I mean I was
just just clicking the picture Jensen
said the shoot reminded him of his past
work with Kim Kardashian to find out why
tune in to ET on Wednesday September 14
you